un inventeur anonyme a mis au point la
voiture à une route à moins que cela ne
soit la voiture sans roues ou la voiture
dans la roue la roue sans voiture on ne
sait plus est effectivement difficile de
bien saisir le concept de cette voiture
belge des années 50
et vous allez le voir dans l'univers
automobile des inventions disons
original il y en a eu en 1952 par
exemple cette voiture ne passait pas
inaperçu sur les routes américaines
sa particularité je vous laisse la
découvrir au prix d'une simple marche
arrière en quatre minutes
l'automobile française elle est en un
tournemain vous êtes emporté en toute
sécurité par cette moderne et
confortable machines volantes autres
créations originales en 1970 et elle
vaut le détour
ceci est la première automobile l'auto
module un objet roulant non identifié
imaginez en 1970 par l'artiste jean
pierre pontier une création conçue pour
une publicité une auto module c'est très
beau et une automobile fait elle est
plus humble l'inventeur de l'auto-moto
une voiture sur deux roues remarque
écrit plus tôt alain gène amusant et
curieux qu'autre chose parce qu'en
réalité il vaut mieux rouler sur quatre
au cola dessus des engins amusant pour
de grands enfants en 1974 cet homme
inventait la deux chevaux électrique à
hélices une bonne idée écologique mais
surtout encore une fois une belle
fantaisie c'est un amusement de
retraités je fais ça pour m'amuser
j'espère améliorer la batture 2
dans les années 80 cet inventeur s'est
lui aussi bien amusé en imaginant cette
voiture multifonctions vous n'avez pas
eu le temps de prendre votre douche ce
matin pas de panique
faites le dans votre voiture c'est la
seule voiture à notre connaissance qui
est l'eau courante chaudes et froides
alors après la voiture baignoire bernard
envisage de faire un autobus piscine et
pour finir plus qu'une simple invention
originale voici une révolution en 1961
déjà un inventeur belge avait vu juste
l'avenir de l'automobile résidait dans
la voiture autonome l'antenne détecte
les obstacles et les freins font le
reste
la voiture sans chauffeur enfin
[Musique]